thank you
Pakistan good evening thanks yes ladies
and gentlemen joining us on YouTube uh
welcome to the tourist District campus
or annual general meeting
um just a bit of I think there's there's
no higher arms or biod journals expected
so if they do soon give a bit more
readability and complicated in the cloud
Market approach
um so it just put sorry
if when we go through the votes
obviously all new members we sometimes
keep your hands up high so I was talking
of officers and make sure we have the
right number of old store against or
abstentions because we do need to make
sure the numbers are entirely up for
each post
so he will start the meeting so uh that
is heard any apologies perhaps please
thank you
uh and so the second item on the agenda
is for the election of chair of council
so by part of the nominations please
thanks councilor James it's their second
effort councilor bushby
Council Christopher you second to no
maintenance
are there any other nominations
you know if we could go to the vote so
all those in favor of council must be
being chair Council please show your
hands
and any against
any abstentions
um
declaration acceptance office please
okay I've done this question
I don't understand
the chair of Council of college system
Council declared I'm going to take that
office upon myself and with Julie and
faith and fulfill the duties of it
according to without my judgment and
ability
well thank you for that vote of
confidence answers do you appreciate
that
moving on to the next item on the agenda
that Vice chair of the council
um
I'd like to nominate commissioner Peter
Christine if I Sharon you have a second
rupees oh that's a second then okay all
in favor please show
foreign
[Music]
District Council declared and I take
that office upon myself and moved
heavily and Pastor Lee fulfill the
duties of it according to the back of my
judgment and ability
whatever
okay now you move on to the leader of
the council
then
I do apologize first mistake first
meeting our item four on the agenda uh
public contributions
the members of the public wish to speak
on any
we've got no one registered tune okay
five uh considered correspondence or
other business especially brought four
of other direction of the chair I have a
professional development no true
okay now item six brings us on to the
election of the leader of the county
yeah the secondary
yeah I second uh councilor James thank
you
been proposed and seconded all in favor
please show
any against
and only abstentions
thank you
seven moving on to the election of the
Deputy leader of the council
uh I'd like to propose a pension pair
proposed them engines continues this
Deputy lead open cancer thank you is
there a secondary
yeah I'd like to Second uh councilor
player Hudson here
all in favor please show
[Music]
any against
abstentions
foreign
[Music]
and the size of each committee
um at each AGM
um as you'll see the reference under the
terms are attached
um to the report Pages four through two
if
26.
you want me to take with them
individually if you would that's reason
so we have the community and resources
Unity
um number of seats
are 12 for community and resources and
you'll see the committed parents of uh
where the solver policy framework the
budget and the council's objectives and
priorities
that in turn we turn to the council's
overview and scrutiny committees again
the terms of reference are attached but
the internal scripturally committee
exercises and functions in respect of
the council policies divisions
performance Frameworks and actions with
an inward facing and that's for internal
and external is similar and the the
difference is they look at external
bodies that the council uh
funds or has any um reference to
and then we have the audit and
governance committees
um purpose of the audience as governance
committees is to provide Assurance to
the Council of risk management within
the council and the control processes
that the council has in place and it's
to act as a critical friends to the
council functions
the audio governance committee currently
has seven members
and then we have the plans committee
which is uh responsible for uh
developmental control enforcement and
the council's chief reservation system
the plans committee currently has nine
members
licensing committee carries out the
function of the council's licensing
Authority
um so it deals with a whole host of
issues but Hackney carriage and private
higher Vehicles boats Street collection
Animal Welfare
Etc
and the Quorum or the current membership
of the licensing committee is six
members
and then moving on to the council
standard committee it's to assist in
promoting and maintaining high standards
of conduct by the members and
Cooperative members of tourist District
Council and to deal with any reports
submitted by the monitoring officero in
relation to members
uh the current Quorum for standards
committee is nine members
and then we have independent members
also
moving on to the uh
joint planning and policy committee and
this is currently made up this is a
joint committee with our neighboring
Council North Devon District Council
um the community is currently made up
for the from the lead members for
economy environments climates planning
Housing and Community or any such
members as TDC shall consider
appropriate
then we have the Hub Awards
um the harbor board receives report from
reports from the operational services
manager
um affected the management of Biddeford
Harbor and will make any recommendations
to the community and resourcing
committee
um that the hoverboards fees fit
um the group currently consists of five
members of tourist District Council
including the chair of community and
resources committee
and the chair of the working group shall
also be the chair of the community and
resources committee
we have the project sorry property and
major projects working group
um
members of this group of four which
comprises of the leader of the council
the deputy leader of the council the
chair of community and resources
committee and another member appointed
annually by full Council and the Quorum
for property and major projects is
currently two
and then moving on to the council and
climate change working group
um the purpose of the group is to form
the Strategic Direction and oversight
um to enable tourist District Council to
achieve our Targets on carbon neutrality
by 2013. again the private uh change
working group reports to the humidity
and resources committee
the membership level for this group is
for
um but can be expanded with agreement by
the group
that I'm happy to take any questions
so
people exactly
um do you need a personal denomination
we do I'm just coming after that okay
Okay so we've had that um
presentation from Stacy can I have a
proposal or a second please
in that case I'm happy to propose that
we accept best name
thank you okay all in favor please show
enormous again
the item nine has allocation of seats
and they put into Political groups such
as Pages 27 and 28 and don't do again
and Stacy thank you Chad
um so again it's the requirement of the
council's Constitution that full Council
approved the number of seats on the
Committees allocated to each of the
political groups each year at the AGM
um a committee seats are allocated on a
politically proportional Port Royal
basis based on the number of councilors
per group to see
allocation have been calculated and
hopefully members mean we will have the
table in in front of them
so
the recommendation is to ask members to
approve the number of seats allocated to
those committees as detailed
anyone got any questions before we
actually do that
okay it's been performed by Council of
Ford someone that second that comes to
lock
all a favorite please show
you announce again thank you
okay item ten you're having a busy night
Stacy membership of committees Pages 29
and 31.
thank you chair so I've just outlined
the committee's
um at an agenda item eight
and it is also a requirement that
um Council agree the members serving on
each of these committees
um in line with the numbers agreed
um so it's the full Council to over
approved or for this to be delegated to
group leaders to agree at a later date
I'd like to recommend that this is
deferred to group leaders after
um
the allocations have been made and
nominations have been determined tonight
and to be presented to an export Council
okay
I second that check wait he can't
remember all our favorite Michelle
the anonymous again doing very well
okay item 11 bridges on the election of
chairs and vice chairs
so the first one we have to consider is
the chair of uh CNR Community Resources
committee
have some games I would like to compose
Council Bob Hayes uh
right and proposed and seconded the show
of iron space and failure
okay and again
and extensions
thank you very much
[Music]
the next uh one is the vice chair of CNR
Mr thanks
well yes I'd like to propose cancer
Ronald dark
the second for them yeah Oscar Ford
proposing Saturday
all in favor please show
okay
and again
and abstentions
okay thank you very much how are you
doing
to the chair of ordering governance
and governance
for that Mr President
thank you okay the proposed and seconded
a little favor please show
and again
extensions
here
the next item is the vice chair of
ordering governance
so
Newton I've proposed councilor June Gunn
again
thank you very much
okay it's been proposed and seconded or
unfavorable show
yeah I've seen animals thank you very
much
the next item is the chair of the plans
connecting
okay I'm happy to compare this with
every soccer is Chairman
thank you counselor Ford
and propose a second then all in favor
please show
and against
extension
okay the next one is the vice chair of
plans
about what it's about to be names
okay cancel it all
back in
casual afford you just beat cancel a
home probably hunk and then so you set
them in all in favor please show
begins
extensions
later you didn't vote for otherwise
so we got four against her abstention
sorry you know
thank you
okay now move on to
like Manchester yeah licensing you know
sorry customer care
of Licensing okay
second advice a second yeah
I didn't quite hear it myself it's been
proposed unseconded all in favor of
Michelle
thank you
again
no moving on then to the vice chair of
Licensing
Mr Brighton has proposed the capital
assignment thank you
thank you second after that and second
that one thank you
all in favor please show
Anonymous again
moving all then
two
the chair of internal OS
I'd like to nominate account for Simon
news thank you any other nominations
I've got his proposed best there
okay
second of Country Newton I'll second
Andrew
the second or four
seven thank you
okay so
um it's been proposed and seconded um
assume this boost kind of show off hands
and favorite things
okay
and then four potentially that way
yeah
21 for Country Newton 14 country
why they come on to Vice chair of
internal OS
something
okay
I'm happy about it
until I propose a counselor on a job
okay
we've just done something
if I should have seen an aria so that
was kind of crazy wasn't that
seconded by
um
the anonymous
onto the chair of external RNs
okay
at that chair I'd like to Second uh
propose the secondary all in favor
please show it
okay
any against
on abstentions
two two
okay
now we need
um nomination for vice care of external
OS
professor honkin
setting up for that yeah
exactly
I'd like to not make houses
[Music]
okay we've got two candidate services so
we take
pressure
yeah yeah okay councilor Brenton has
been proposed however Joe's house in
favor please
yeah and then show offense in support of
potential Harding please
things that you have seen and government
right we're one short with students
creating there comes the green which
scandal
foreign
numbers are
that kids
thank you Federal sanctions to
abstention do you know what we're doing
yeah
[Music]
25 Council Brenton yeah
oops
okay next item is the chair of the
standards committee
the second for that
yes I'd like to send them Facebook and
seconded show hands in favor
any against
the abstentions
and then on to the last one Vice chair
of standards
culminations
I'd like to propose powerful kids again
second round that's the fourth secondary
I'm super casual
Carl Hawkins has been proposed and
seconded all your favorite Fisher
if you're anonymous thank you
yeah
yeah item 12 on your agenda is a scheme
of delegations which is pages 32-61 on
your agenda once again Stacy is going to
repeat this
thank you Chad
once again it's a requirements
sort of form
ulations
in the Constitution and I went uh run
through it all but it's on pages 34 to
61 of your agenda
foreign
just accept them
I'll promote it from the chair
all in favor of Bishop
the country okay I didn't item 13 on the
agenda substitution scheme pages 62-64
what's against Nathan
some Council also needs to agree the
substitution scheme which is set out on
page 64 of your agenda
um which still some situations where
members aren't able to attend a
committee and need to obtain a
substitute so it sets out specifically
um when you can and when you can't
substitute
um so overview and spiritually committee
members can't
substitute for community and resources
and auditing governance uh may not
substitute on overview and scrutiny uh
for the very reason that if you're
making decisions and taking the
community and resources committee
wouldn't be appropriate to speak to
Nigerian decision making and and from an
audit and governance perspective
um you're reviewing the risk management
of the council as a whole so again
wouldn't be appropriate to bring
reviewing your own decisions that that
you may have made an alternative
committee
thank you station or proportional share
we accept that
yeah
James I can do that all in favor please
show
foreign
against and abstentions please
Bob I don't think you're having that
either way didn't it
oh um
[Music]
thank you
okay item 14 a membership of outside
body speed is 65 to 68.
it's again station so tourist District
councilman sits on various external
organizations on behalf of times
Business Council you'll see the various
organizations listed at page 67 and 68
of your agenda that includes uh the
benefit of bay Chamber of Commerce a bit
of obey children and Center benefit
Community archive Council
a BH Canal Trust
or mocking towns initiative hold worthy
um and many others so it's again a
requirement that full Council formally
approve which Council fit on these
external bodies or in the alternative
that decision is delegated to group
leaders for group leaders to agree Mr
Olson I'd like to propose this is again
delegated to group leaders after
consultation with their members
well I was just going to say that um can
I ask your counselors if they're aware
of any of these bodies have stopped I
mean the first one on the list has gone
and also some of the contact addresses
are wrong Holyfield Mrs Ferguson they do
need updating so if any counselor is
aware of it if you could turn on the
opposite
thank you
okay so it's been proposed a second is
that this is delegated to group leaders
in favor Bishop
Mr X
your favorite
animal
15 is members to active tolerance board
Pages 69 the 70
um the chief Executives can present this
item uh thanks chair
um so for those new councilors to the
current so I just hear a quick
background to porridge is uh so uh over
the last two years the council has taken
back it's the running of its Leisure
Services based at Paul's worthy torrent
turn and Northern and in doing so set up
a company to operate those Services
um when it was set up the principal
decided that it would have a board board
of directors to run and operate that
that company and the current makeup of
the board is for counselors being the
leader of the council the chair of
community and resources the lead member
of the community culture and Leisure and
one further answer to be appointed at
each AGM the other officers are myself
and Sean Carney who was the head of
communities in place and one
non-executive director Judith Gentry
so chair
um as the council's already appointed
the leader and the chair community and
resources those two appointments are
dealt with
the lead members is an exciting on the
agenda and it's recounted to decide to
appoint a fourth member to the board
announced a recommendation Journey we're
saying that we don't need a proposal
segment of this dick right and yeah we
we watch if members are
chair could I personally carry that
forward to
um group leaders
um and when we as the chief exec said we
have settled two of the seats we need to
deal with the other one which is the
lead number one culture and Leisure and
then we will also have to come back with
a independent member of this Council
that is not tied to those roles if I'm
composer to carry that forward to the
next
meeting which we need to do early urgent
need to find out these seams and then it
can be confirmed at the June meeting
thank you
a little secondary proposal Okay so
we've been proposing second did that we
defer this the subsequent meeting wrong
favorite show
okay
yeah so item 16 then the lead member
Pages 71 72.
um uh all councils responsible for
um approving each of these members uh so
on page 72 of your report there's the
current list of lead members who are all
Council to approve them either tonight
or again as Council James delegated on
who
yeah thank you Chad
um
obviously some of them are reflect on
Whose chairs and things like that we've
only just settled that and so I've
proposed I believe
defer this to uh good leaders and each
group leader come forward and we'll
discuss with those in where in
relationship who's sharing things as
well because that usually it has an
effective leaders meeting and then it
comes back to the gym meeting
all in favor of this show
hello just be told when the next full
council meeting is in June he's updated
16.
19th of June
okay
the item 17 is the important of the
section 151 officer Pages 73 to 74. what
were you against me uh thanks Jay
um so our current uh section 1.1 officer
finance manager David Hayes uh will be
retiring uh about six weeks time the 4th
of July the council has a legal
requirement to have a post folder an
officer of the council in that role and
specifically designated for that role
um David David notice his intentions are
as higher uh some time ago so we've been
through a recruitment process which
comes to the Hudson and Council James
were both part of the interview and
recruitment process uh was it successful
in being able to appoint uh Gordon
Bryant to the role of finance manager
and Gordon won't be able to start with
the council until the 31st of July but
four pounds us to resolve to a point
that post as section 151 officer and
chair that's the recommendation of the
report
having to propose that from the chair
you know I'm having a second I did all
of everybody please show
um
could I just say what I think it has
been to work with David Hayes
slowly came used to his sense of humor
slowly is the right word
um
so we will be best
um we're hoping the gentleman we've
entered uh interviewed
um we will have a big step to make up to
come up to Davis level but I just hope
he's got a slightly different sense of
Humane
thank you
okay moving on to item 18.
Arnold part two items so All That
Remains is to meet him with everyone a
very good evening and thank you for
attending this meeting I look forward to
seeing all you of your counselors and